in the wood-paneled chapel of the
catholic university of louvain in
belgium
a priest lights a candle and kneels
before the statue of christ for his
daily devotion
his name is georges lemaitre
and it is 1927. as he rises his eyes
wander to the towering windows that line
the chapel's walls
and to the stars twinkling in the early
evening light
he smiles in distant reflection
imagining the sequence of events that
brought that starlight
to the belgian sky but
despite his faith lumetra's beliefs were
lacking
a creator so fundamental to the catholic
doctrine
he had no need for divine intervention
when it came to the making of the
universe
no seven-day miracle instead he saw it
as a natural
consequence of natural laws and
processes
proved by mathematics and visible in the
movements of the heavens themselves
his extraordinary insight would earn him
two nobel prize nominations
for george lemaitre was more than just
a catholic priest he was also a
theoretical physicist a cosmologist
fascinated with the workings of god's
perfect universe
it was here in naivan that he began work
on a theory that would come to shape our
modern
understanding of the cosmos all based on
the remarkable observation
that space seemed to be
expanding
mathematics had laid out the history of
the universe
and now lemaitre traces it backwards in
his mind's eye
he imagines a time before humans or
indeed any living thing inhabiting the
earth
before that of course the earth must
have formed as a barren rocky ball
around the glowing sun
before that the sun ignited in a blaze
of nuclear glory crushed into being by
the irresistible force of gravity
in a vast cloud of gas and dust that gas
and dust was a consequence of many
generations of stars living and dying
before our own
igniting fusing elements and exploding
in terrific supernova
that spread their elemental waste
products across the cosmos
he imagined a time before these many
lineages of stars before the chemical
complexity that we enjoy
when only hydrogen and helium floated
inert in a lightless universe
if space is expanding now then in the
reverse chronology of lemaitre's mind it
is contracting
there would be a point in this dark
gassy cosmos before the first star
when all the matter in the universe was
compressed into a vastly smaller space
atoms would become packed so tightly
that even photons are unable to pass
through
there are no light sources here but it
doesn't matter the universe is
utterly opaque when the contracting
reversed universe crushes down even
further the atoms themselves are crushed
first into subatomic particles and then
into pure energy
in this small dense universe there is
only radiation
here even lumetra's imagination begins
to falter
the universe can become even smaller
even hotter
but what happens then
lumetra pushes the unanswerable from his
mind content in having grasped 13
billion or so years of cosmological
history
and unperturbed by the mysteries
contained within the first fraction
of a second
but the big bang theory of which lumetra
was unknowingly the first true proponent
has been the subject of debate research
and speculation
for nearly 100 years
how did the universe begin
what was the trigger for its incredible
expansion
and could our simple matter brains
ever even comprehend the real truth
[Music]
[Music]
before le metre studies of the cosmos
had largely focused on our own place
within it
as well as observations to determine its
composition and extent
the 13th century philosopher sigur of
brabant was alone in venturing the
statement that the universe
was eternal with no beginning his
heretical views
outraged the theologians of the time and
earned him condemnation by the pope in
1277.
rumor has it he was murdered with a pen
a symbol of the damage his ideas had
done
since then no serious scholar had
contemplated changing history or
a beginning and so
lumetra's calculations rocked the
cosmological world
but they were not embraced by everybody
[Music]
the idea was that the universe started
its life a finite time ago
in a single huge explosion and that the
present expansion is a relic of the
violence of this explosion
this big bang idea seemed to me to be
unsatisfactory even before detailed
examination showed that it leads to
serious difficulties
one respected but controversial
astronomer fred hoyle
railed against lumetra's expanding
universe history even
coining the term big bang as an insult
for the implication of an expanding
universe is that
at some point it must have begun
expanding
and at some point the universe itself
must have begun
this hoyle confidently declared was
pseudoscience
little different from trying to justify
the existence of a creator
the only reason he said that we were so
attracted to this
novel big bang theory was because the
teachings of the book of genesis
are so ingrained into our collective
psyche
and yet lemaitre was quite happy to keep
physics and religion separate
his mathematics didn't yearn for
theological validation
and they were supported by real
observations of the real
universe made by eminent astronomer
edwin hubble
just a few years later from the mount
wilson observatory northeast of los
angeles hubble had gazed tirelessly
through the largest aperture telescope
of the time
peering at some of the dimmest parts of
the night sky
his measurements would prove
conclusively the long-held suspicion
that there were more galaxies than just
our own milky way
but they would also show something that
nobody
had expected luminous objects like stars
emit light as a result of the fusion in
their cores
the colour and characteristics of that
light depends on the temperature
and the composition of the star but it
also depends
on the star's movement just as an
emergency vehicle sounding a siren will
sound different when it's moving towards
us
or away from us so too the light from
the star will be altered
when it's moving closer or further away
in sound the phenomenon is known as a
doppler shift
and in light it's redshift the light
waves emitted by stars moving away from
us are stretched out
the same energy must now cover a greater
distance so the wavelength is subtly
increased
in the visible spectrum the longer
wavelengths of light are coloured
red to our eyes and so receding stars
appear more red than they actually are
[Music]
hubble wasn't the first to discover
redshift in astronomical objects but his
observations at mount wilson did uncover
a surprising truth every galaxy he
studied
was redshifted every single galaxy
was moving away
although at first this would seem to
support religious notions of the earth
being the center of the universe
the truth is stranger still hubble saw
that the more distant galaxies receded
much more quickly than those close by
and this could only be possible if the
whole of
space was expanding
these observations were a striking
vindication of lumetra's mathematics
and of the concept of a tiny beginning
to our universe
in 1964 researchers at bell labs in
holmdale new jersey
were using a gigantic horn antenna to
tune into radio waves bounced off some
of the earlier satellites
the work demanded unprecedented
precision and the scientists went to
great lengths to eliminate
all possible outside sources of
interference
but despite their best efforts their
results were plagued with a persistent
noise
they couldn't eliminate at first they
thought it could have been the results
of pigeons roosting in the shelter of
the huge antenna
their droppings disturbing the signal or
perhaps it could have been interference
from bustling 1960s new york city
some 50 kilometers away but eventually
it became clear that the noise wasn't
pigeons
or people it was coming from outside
our galaxy
it was a property of the universe which
we now recognize
as cosmic microwave background radiation
this radiation is a remnant of a time
when the universe was very small and
very very hot as predicted by lumetra's
calculations
the expansion of space has since spread
that radiation out
stretching the once intense heat waves
into microwaves with a background
temperature of just three degrees above
absolute zero these radiation scars
burned into the fabric of space of
vindication
of the truth of the big bang
the big bang theory is now the accepted
model for the cosmos
a picture of expansion over some 13.8
billion years but there is still much
work to be done
much understanding to be sought the
nature of the universe's first moments
are still
shrouded in mystery and so many
questions
remain unanswered what really was
the big bang and why does it break our
understanding
of the universe
[Music]
models of an expanding universe were
originally based upon albert einstein's
theories of general relativity
which he had formulated some 20 years
earlier but when einstein heard about
this radical new theory
he was uncomfortable he declared that
lumetra's maths were sound
but his physics was atrocious the
problem was once again the implication
that an expanding
universe must have had a beginning but
here it wasn't the theological arguments
that casted into doubt
rather the fact that the physics of the
time had no explanation
for how such a thing could happen or
what it even looked like
le metre extrapolated the universe back
to what he describes
as the primeval atom which contained
within it the potential for the entire
immeasurable universe we can trace the
beginning of time and space back to this
single point but as for what it looked
like
or how it worked even now physicists
aren't sure when all the stuff of the
universe is compressed into an
increasingly smaller space
the laws of physics dictate that the
density will increase
and so will the temperature we have a
good idea of what happens to mata under
these kinds of conditions
thanks to small scale experiments in
gigantic particle accelerators
but our experiments and our
understanding can only go so far
after that things become
unclear beyond the realm of particles
and subatomic quarks and their
mysterious companions
is a compressed universe of pure energy
where weirdness rules the fundamental
laws of physics which govern everything
we see and experience
break down it becomes harder and harder
to predict
how this hyperdense and hyper-hot
primeval
universe worked how small could it
really get
what makes it begin to expand
in the last few decades theoretical
physicists have grappled with tentative
theories
one that reigned for a long time is that
the cosmos began as a gravitational
singularity
a single one-dimensional point from
which all of time and space were birthed
this is not dissimilar to the
singularity at the center of black holes
like the one that lurks at the center of
our galaxy
the singularity is a point that is so
immeasurably dense
that the gravitational pull from it
reaches infinity
in the case of black holes the gravity
is so strong that light cannot escape
but a singularity
at the beginning of the universe would
have no light to consume
as it already contained everything there
was to contain
if the universe today is infinite in
extent then the infinitely small
singularity would have a density and
temperature
that would also extend to infinity
concepts of infinity stretch our minds
to breaking point
and that's not the only problem with
gravitational singularity as a starting
point
if at the moment of its beginning the
cosmos had been an arbitrarily dense and
hot point
then scientists believe the universe
that resulted from it
would have looked very different from
the one in which we find ourselves
there should be huge fluctuations in
temperature and density from one end of
the cosmos to another
and there aren't there should be ultra
high temperature relics of the
infinitely high temperature state
but there aren't space itself
should be more lumpy
but it isn't in fact the universe is
remarkably uniform when looked at
as a whole the fluctuations in
temperature and density that we see
average out and you would struggle to
pinpoint yourself in space
based on these kinds of features alone
cosmologists
go so far as to say that it is smooth
and the chances of a singularity
creating a smooth universe
are infinitely small
but there is another option
it may have all begun with a period
known
as inflation
during this inflationary period right at
the earliest moments of the cosmos
space expanded exponentially
doubling in size from one moment to the
next things that increase exponentially
get very big very fast and so this
cosmic inflation was sufficient to put
the bang
into the big bang itself expanding much
faster than
even the speed of light it was enough
to stretch the universe flat and to make
it uniform
all over which is precisely what we see
today
according to the theory the universe was
imbued with energy
which caused the exponential expansion
when the exponential expansion ended
although we don't know why it ended
the energy inherent to the universe is
converted into matter and radiation
marking the beginning of time and space
as we understand it
the features of the modern universe only
allow us to see
the final decillionth of a second's
worth of this inflation
that's 1 over 10 to the power 33 during
which time
physics made a little more sense but we
still don't know how long
the inflationary period lasted could the
inflation itself have started with a
singularity
logic says no if exponential expansion
means doubling in size
then running that in reverse we see the
universe shrink to half its size
then a quarter an eighth a sixteenth and
so on
the fractions become vanishingly small
but
they never reach zero from a purely
mathematical point of view
a singularity of zero size is an
impossibility
so right now we don't have the tools to
understand or describe inflation
any further back we may never understand
it
the origins of cosmic inflation extend
back into the frog
of pre-time beyond the reach of science
and into the realm
of pure speculation thus
the big bang is perhaps not the
beginning of the universe at all
but rather the line drawn in the cosmic
sand
marking the limits of our own
understanding
not a beginning but a history whose
opening paragraph
may be several pages in but is the first
to make any real sense
and yet if we really stretch our minds
to the limit
of our comprehension the extreme edges
of theoretical physics
may give us the tools to break through
that fog
[Music]
in 1981 in the shadow of saint peter's
basilica in vatican city
the top cosmologists of the time met for
a conference
organized by the pontifical academy of
sciences
gone are the days when the pope would
issue condemnations of cosmological
thinking
or perhaps it is precisely because the
favored big bang theories now point
towards a mysterious beginning for the
universe
that theological institutions see
parallels of their work in mathematical
cosmology
regardless at this conference among the
hushed gardens of the vatican 39 year
old stephen hawking
is an honoured guest and he presents
some of his latest thinking
on the beginning of the universe
he addresses the assembled scholars his
own voice cutting through the last
shreds of muttered conversation
his disability has already begun to take
its toll and the close friend sits
alongside him
translating his words for others in the
room to understand
but while his words may seem ill-formed
his
thoughts have never been clearer even if
they too
seem to make no sense
the universe is finite he says but it
has
no edge someone standing at the far end
of the observable cosmos
13.8 billion light years away would see
space
exactly as we do as you go back to the
beginning of the universe
space and time become fuzzy but they
curve around and cap
off much like the south pole of our
planet
trying to understand what came before
the universe
is like asking what is south of the
south pole
the question itself is meaningless
hawking's no boundary proposal rocked
the scientific community
and left the rest of the world
scratching their heads
while we may understand that there is
nothing south of the south pole
seeing that in the context of all of
space and time
is a difficult concept for us to grasp
as we strive to understand our place in
the unfathomable cosmos we can't help
but grasp the answers to potentially
unanswerable questions what was there
before what is the universe expanding
into and why did it start
at all
[Music]
testable science cannot give us the
answers
we seek time is a fundamental property
of the universe in existence and so
there was
no time before the big bang there was
no before space
is a fundamental property of the
universe in existence
so there was no space before the big
bang
there is no outside
the cosmos just
is
something that breaks all the laws of
physics is impossible to visualize
let alone study but even in the face of
the truly mysterious
the modern scientific approach isn't
content with simply saying that we don't
know
that we can't know scientists continue
to speculate they take an obscure
property of the universe or a
mathematical concept and run with it
to come up with speculative theoretical
possibilities that might
just might give us a pinhole view into
the impossible before
and the intangible why
one of the most popular pieces of
speculation has become known
as the big bounce in which the universe
is eternal but transitions between an
expanding state
described by the big bang and a
contracting one
known as the big crunch the idea of this
endlessly inflating and deflating cosmos
has been around since the early 20th
century
but it was only in the last decade or so
that physicists have discovered how it
might be possible
the theory posits that in the very
earliest moments of the universe
everything is so small that reality is
governed by quantum
mechanics the strange properties of the
quantum world mean that a contracting
universe can be saved from complete
collapse
by quantum tunneling from a point just
before the collapse
to a point just after it transitioning
instantaneously from a contracting
space-time to an expanding one
at the other end of the universe's
timeline after a big bang style
expansion for billions of years
it's hypothesized that the density of
matter in the cosmos
will have sufficient gravity to overcome
the force driving expansion
and eventually reverse it but
the latest observations of the modern
universe suggest that the expansion
hubble saw back in the 40s
is not in fact slowing down but is
actually
accelerating this is a spanner in the
works for the big crunch
but there is another option
[Music]
in 2010 british theoretical physicist
roger penrose
presented a new theory of conformal
cyclic cosmology
founded in some of the most complex
mathematics and theoretical physics
available to cosmologists today
the model relies on the concept of
conformal geometry
which concerns the geometry of shapes
irrespective of their size
a chessboard has the same geometry the
same number of squares the same aspect
ratio regardless of how big it is
whether it's a tiny pocket-sized board
or a huge garden set
the game is still played the same and
these principles apply to our own
universe at the points in its history
when we lose
track of scale one of these points is in
the murky high
energy instant just before the big bang
the other
is in the far distant future when black
holes have swallowed everything
and the overall energy is so low that
all space and time
cease to have any meaning although many
would consider a tiny hot universe and a
huge cold one to be about as different
as it's possible to be
according to conformal geometry they are
equivalent
a huge cold universe at the end of its
life behaves just the same
as a hot one at its beginning penrose
uses these mind-bending principles to
reason that one
naturally leads on from the other that
we are living through a single
eon of our universe and that in a google
years or so
the loss of scale at the death of the
universe will lead to the big bang
of a brand new eon at the beginning
of a new history
[Music]
in both the big bounce and conformal
cyclic cosmologies
our big bang is both a beginning and an
end and is just one of many big bangs in
the endless stream of universal
existence
but there is an even stranger theory
with its origins in strings
in the spring of 1995 at the university
of southern california in los angeles
the american theoretical physicist
edward whitton
made an extraordinary announcement that
was music to the ears of string
theory scholars worldwide string theory
models had been developed over the
preceding 50 years
to explain the fundamental nature of
mata on an unimaginably small scale
it claims that all particles are
ultimately composed of one-dimensional
strings
that move through space and interact
with one another but to explain
everything in our universe
different versions of string theory
argued that there must be other entities
with more dimensions two-dimensional
sheets or three-dimensional volumes
and even more this model which was
intended to unify all of physics
had done little more than divide the
scientific community
but edward whitton rejected such
divisive thinking
he conjectured that all the different
versions of string theory
could all be true if they were
incorporated
into an 11-dimensional reality
his proposal of this so-called
super-string
theory sparked a flurry of research and
offered a new if perplexing possibility
in super-string theory space-time is
described by no less
than 11 dimensions in this theoretical
framework our own
universe which we experience in the
three dimensions of space
and one dimension of time can be
considered a mere portion
of the whole a so-called brain
in the bulk of hyperspace physicists
suggest that our universe developed from
the energy released when higher order
brains collided
the energy from the collision provides
the motion force for the big bang
and subsequent expansion of the universe
but it can't last forever
tension between these higher order
brains will cause them to retract
and re-collapse after a mere trillion
years
bringing an end to our universe that we
are unable to visualize
or even comprehend this heady theory
is known as the equiotic model referring
to ancient myths
that see the world born in a fiery
explosion
for now we have no tools to detect the
higher dimensions if they really exist
so like the other theories that try to
explain and justify the cosmos
they remain little more than highly
informed speculation
but the big bounce the conformal cycles
and the equiotic brain cosmos are all
possibilities that lie at the bleeding
edge of modern cosmology
like all good theories they try to make
predictions that we can
test through observation and experiment
but so far
no evidence has come to light to give us
any real clue
[Music]
our understanding of the cosmos relies
like a house of cards
on our understanding of physics and
mathematics which continues to change
and evolve the true nature of the big
bang
and the meaning of the universe as a
whole may always be incomprehensible
to our monkey brains or perhaps
a new revelation will turn everything on
its head tomorrow
we can only keep asking and trying to
see
through the frog
[Music]
you've been watching the entire history
of the universe don't forget to like and
subscribe and leave a comment to tell us
what you think
and we'll see you next time